how's it going bros my name is fear
[Applause]
anyway welcome to to give us the force
hopefully we could end this custom story
right now
the thing is the bruise right there like
what to do maybe fire on pastor should I
run past them
okay three three - what gap yeah I can
do this
Oh get me up yes probably yes volunteers
got nothing I have nothing that's great
ah son of a [ __ ] got me ah man
your flesh shall be molded into
something far greater oh maybe a purse I
could be a purse I would love to be a
purse
maybe maybe like an and handkerchief or
something anyway this is good apparently
everyone was like huh Oh is he in here
broke
apparently it's hey hey hey bro I don't
want to fight I'm just gonna go here
somewhere follow this yes all right
apparently everyone's I only need to cut
up the heart from the gangbang good
going buddy hey des chef smells foul
I'll need to get buzzing all against fit
in hey Brown hired him bro that's just a
rock so we're gonna stab this mother
[ __ ] Chuck I can't that this half
that's what I do it just smells foul all
right here we go
I never noticed but the
the light spider legs was before
Crabtree Anna it's kind of weird I don't
I don't even know anymore nur but let's
finish this custom study I just have to
walk up these stairs I don't know if I
can do it
I played I've been running from millions
of monsters this custom story had all
[ __ ] monster I don't know the stairs
might be my my last ok ok I made it
Jesus Christ
alright so now I need sacrifice and hard
I do this [ __ ] every day so it's no
problem for me how do I do this out
there we go oh and blade extends to come
alright let's do this [ __ ] that's not so
nice something something else are we
turning into the bro is that it
oh the [ __ ] a bro army it's you guys oh
oh the bug what's going on hey
alright that was to finish up to give
this too far
excellent castle story I really enjoyed
playing it if you have any suggestions
on what I should play next
feel free to live in a comic trekker I
got a lot of suggesting for quiet I
might check that out anyway
listen a lot of people working on it
actually no fixes whatever like a
favorite and all that kind of stuff and
I'll show you mine alright how's it
going bros my name is beard welcome to
madness chapter 3 demo I don't know what
happened to chapter one or two I dunno
this is made by the guy who made too
much for my new - series all right it's
a new series but it's Chapter two Adam I
don't even know it's made by the guy who
made stayin alive so Casey bros watch
that then um I don't even know what a
more
it shouldn't be too serious in this map
freakin defrag is going on your mind is
a dangerous place
I wouldn't stay long if I were you
the demons will drag it down the abyss
of madness time is taking Banyon look
how fast I'm going yeah yeah hey hey
what is this this looks scary this is
music what hello Jennifer
what are you doing that's what you get
girl boy mono [ __ ] sizzle agonist
penis
I need my ylang-ylang hello
how is it possible that we yet every
time its price don't spam me
okay I think barrels what are you doing
here it's my castle where does map the
sign ever
hey what is he doing what are you doing
Brock oh [ __ ] that
push this on him I don't even know are
you coming from Wow it's fascist Venus
blogging me I'm Fanning it up for him
like burning balls
ah this is my nightmare ah ah thank you
jump out Jesus Christ
what do you want from me all right I
think we get Jeff yes it'll be doing
down there
Jeff now that we're good
barrels get [ __ ] out of here this
[ __ ] pub I'll have to jump here oh
yeah I have to jump here holy [ __ ]
alright what what it would be as if I
could see anything
what
brow so close so close oh thank god a
[ __ ] Samsung we shut up oh they can
respawn that's great to know
what's going on here that's no problem I
mean I mean this cattle I'm gonna get
that chest it's gonna be a Zelda moment
do do do did punch with tenth Taylor's
Holly oh I don't think they like that
hey what are you doing on my face Bob ah
my face [ __ ] alright yeah you're
standing on my face Brock I'm gonna get
up hey you're [ __ ] heavy I described
oh geez Reza hurt he's not fast ah you
have to carry on this cousins are
ridiculous
alright
oh yeah all right I think I got a shame
for I don't know if there's anything
more to this to be honest I will I
probably have added this to to give us
the force ending as a bonus or whatever
it's uh anyway hope you bros enjoyed
like a favorite if you did and I'll be
really happy I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]